neumonía malaria diarrea infecciones de
piel y desnutrición infantil en
distintos grados la comunidad llanumami
de Brasil continúa sufriendo las
condiciones vulnerables de vida y la
ausencia de asistencia de salud
muchos están enfermos no hay comida
muchos de nuestros familiares han muerto
muchos ya no mamían muerto
se estima que 30.000 viven en el
territorio indígena más grande que tiene
Brasil equivalente al tamaño de Portugal
y donde 570 niños han muerto en los
últimos tres años las enfermedades del
pueblo indígena desbordan la capacidad
del hospital de niños Santo Antonio el
único del estado de roraima al que
acuden en graves condiciones menores que
tienen entre 29 días y 12 años
las miradas apuntan a la aceleración de
la explotación minera que contaminó Ríos
mató animales arrebató fuentes de agua
potable generó charcos que originan
enfermedades y ocupó los pocos espacios
sanitarios
nos quedamos cuatro años sin asistencia
sanitaria en las comunidades 120
comunidades luchando por la vida más de
20.000 Mineros de oro en tierra indígena
Llano mami con armas intimidando a las
comunidades comunidades que viven con
miedo
el último 20 de enero el Gobierno
Federal declaró una emergencia de salud
pública y desde entonces se tendieron
hospitales de campaña para auxiliar a la
comunidad la situación de los yanumami
se agradó seriamente durante el gobierno
de Jair bolsonaro durante su mandato las
muertes dentro del grupo indígena de la
selva amazónica aumentaron un 28%